why is it cold why is it chunky how did
you put in this I'm Vaughn and my
childhood was defined by American snacks
I'm Brenda I always warn you're raised
in Columbia I do have my own version of
this continuous snacks but I always feel
like I missed out on yours we're on a
mission to bring back those iconic
snacks that our generation wishes we're
back on the shelves whenever we tell
people about this show there is this one
snack that keeps calming bad please
bring back gurus how about we get to
hear from this girl who claims to be a
super dunkaroos fan hi Brendon Vaughan
I'm Deanna I'm a dunker super fan always
used to save them when at lunch like I
never wanted to trade with anybody
Packaging was amazing
the little section for the frosting and
the little cookies the way you could
just scoop out the frosting was just so
beautiful and perfect the flavor of
vanilla funfetti is it the best it seems
like we need to get three things to get
this right I will be donc ability flavor
and the packaging well Brenda I think
we're missing the most important part
what is it does it bring me back do you
want to handle the recipe portion
totally and all handle the packaging I
like the sound good oh my god yes yes
kitchens here
I wish Vaughan was here for this he
asked me to get this bunny looking
cookies making says that there should
taste like dunkaroos
your graham cookies nothing crazy to it
so I kind of know what I'm going for
right now so that's good cooking he does
have a little bit of a tan so I'm gonna
add a little bit of brown sugar for that
this means so much for the people who
have requested this it's just pretty
cool you know to be working into
bringing back something that they love
so that they love since 1992 this is
when they debuted it now I can finish it
out with my hands we're really
keep moving because I have to test this
until we get the right one what we're
gonna try to do is recreate the
packaging I am by no means a crafty DIY
Joanna games but I can try a couple
things first I just need to draw up a
plan
our research team got back to me and
said that the packaging is 5.2 inches
long it's about an inch and a half deep
what I might do first is try to make it
out of hardboard
maybe some tin foil I don't really know
what I'm doing happening here you have a
tiny little arc you fix that up here I
listen cardboard isn't gonna cut it
but you can cut the cardboard use at
least it coming along how's your day are
you gonna make you go right now because
yeah I got some cookies in the oven it's
a master it works it will be great I
trust you baby more than awesome good
luck bye I don't really know what I'm
doing
all right so while we were baking those
cookies I think we need to take care of
that freaking frosting I found this
recipe online that closed for fun Fetty
cake mix the last two ingredients yogurt
and Cool Whip
I can totally dig this this looks like a
kid's party
I can Adam I'm sorry to ambush you with
a camera crew I need help with something
okay so basically we're trying to bring
back dunkaroos dr. rose right yeah do
you remember him of course do you love
them I used to I haven't had him in like
20 years out because they were
discontinued I was trying to build the
container and then it popped into my
mind that you have a 3d printer sure do
so I was wondering would it be possible
to 3d print it
painter yeah totally wait would we also
be able to like design custom cookies to
course yeah let's do it
[Music]
making funny this is like me last summer
to think as Vaughn will stay with three
seasons and what is this these look um
interesting that they smell pretty good
I think I've got something that's gonna
help you what oh shut up i overnighted
some from canada yesterday these are
unfit for human consumption the frosting
looks nasty it's pretty like moldy and
gross it's new cookie it's a bit bigger
and it's also lighter in color okay it
looks it seems as if it's more of like a
shortbread rather than the graham cookie
that we know and love do you have any
frosting is it the first thing we cheese
made what why is it tangy fake frosting
is literally it's like palm oil
shortening like vegetable shortening
powdered sugar the sprinkles are good
you you got that right that's really
cool let me try I think I'm gonna take
us somewhere sure alright you're taking
somewhere I trust you I figure it's time
to try this new icing recipe why do you
know what I trust Vaughn and he knows
that tastes better than I do so this
should be alright
more sugar a lot more sugar
I bought some food grade silicone and
I'm gonna try to use this silicone in
some way to like cast a cookie mold
maybe
wow there's a lot on here that's like
safety danger is there like maybe I feel
like go online and look at a video
something any bond oh yeah
sorry to interrupt I have your cookie
[Applause]
definitely ahead and got some cornflour
so the start makes it alright got very
little time and you were wondering where
the eggs the egg is 11 or so we know we
have some problems with sickness before
brace yourself
expect the worst listen to the base now
we have here molasses it's gonna add a
little bit of that tan collar because
the cookie the real dog's roof is not
very tail I think about why we're doctor
is discontinued we actually you know we
actually try getting in touch with them
but the answer we got is that there are
many factors that came to taking the
decision and that was it this is sick I
got it what what what what you didn't
believe boom right there you made like
big ones small ones maybe this is
awesome oh my god okay now all I need to
do is figure out how to cast a silicone
mold
of these you need a hand seriously yeah
yeah we're gonna have to glue these down
here we're basically mixing the silicon
and we're gonna pour it into this this
is the mold for the mold I want to eat
this my job here is pretty much done
until tomorrow Adam how do I get this
out what we could do is just break the
container these things like are pretty
indestructible we use them for our
spices so the aggressive spices we'll
see if this works
[Music]
literally been at this for almost an
hour and a half do you think that will
work let's see
[Music]
oh my god we're done we're done we're
done oh my god is this childhood this is
beautiful oh my god let's go ahead and
that there's no turning back now
this is so brand new to me but I do
understand what's light to have that
snag that brings you back
everything that we've worked for the
many tears are leading up to this one
moment you have this huge responsibility
of turning food into a time machine
[Music]
Queen Deanna it says Deanna's dunkaroos
the 3d printed the container you want to
go ahead and open these are so beautiful
zoom in on the P all look at that
funfetti you frosting and then there's a
tee and then your Deanna's d that smooth
ball you get one plant does it bring you
back like the packaging is giving me the
nostalgia vibe you feel very special
hold on so she comes right now that we
have the flavor the dunk ability the
packaging and it's taking them back with
it our freaking joke come on come on you
gotta get working
stop trying to eat her cookies oh my god
never did it for the game when I picked
up the mic and made my whole world
changed started back at my bedroom where
the double cassette had nothing to prove
no records to press never follow the
trend
I just kept pursuing to be original